[Music]
if you were to zoom in phase out move in
focus on this human whose cells magnify
as you fly through them and see atoms
looming but you keep shooting past
protons bosons quarks to leave and apart
for particles too big then boom and then
to the intrusion as you hit the
resolution of the universe the strands
of its fabric the tiniest fragment the
planck length past that gravity becomes
fallacy try contrasting that with the
galaxies and to grasp the huge magnitude
of the universe it's unimaginable
but let's try anyway if that insane
length was one dollar bill
then to reach the wavelength of the
smallest particles quarks that are so
fundamental they don't have an inherent
size will be the current price you'd
gain if you sold mount everest made out
of gold
that is insane if you applied the midas
touch to my mind it'd be quite enough to
buy a car to drive in with the glue on
and three corks combined make a large
hadron those guys collide a proton and
to magnify to that size would turn that
midas mountain into a diamond
my mind made of that could buy you an
island next wrap up from quarks and
protons to atoms atoms the fractions of
matter the ones that grant us are
amassing if that cork was counted every
time you take a single breath you'd
respire midas mountains then until your
death yeah and if that life was
compressed into one luck of hair then as
we climb up the rest of these atomic
stares then we pass dna when we get to
my red streak and the size of our cells
we'd equate to every hair on my head
[Music]
the cell represents lifetimes of midas
everest breasts and then you would
stretch it out to the skyline again and
again you'd find you'd circle around the
earth ten times before you meet me and
you right here the reach of a human a
meteorite if we were to choose one song
to represent those horizons and mp3 on
our device then to reach the size of the
earth compared to like our size that's a
terabyte hard drive filled with our
files it seems immense and if we
compress that collection to one word to
represent our world then stealing
coefficients from the planets of the
solar system would let me re-read the
whole of deathly hallows awesome and
then to travel between stars as we take
to the skies we'll be ten times every
word you'll ever say in your life and as
an analogy of the expanse of galaxies up
in space ten times the total of every
word in every book ever made and to move
up to the scale of galaxy clusters would
be every word sent by everyone in
shanghai in london berlin delhi l.a
mumbai sao paulo and moscow jakarta
karachi dubai telford tokyo and
stockholm and then to galaxy super
clusters in the large-scale structure
with filaments that feel inadequately
described as humongous since if we stay
with the scale of earth as a word that
equates to all the words everyone alive
today will ever say and finally we reach
the biggest physical thing we can
confirm the indescribable size of the
observable universe which would be more
than every word that every person has
ever said every word that was ever
written every word that was ever read
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
to summarize every word that every
person has ever said in their life where
each word implies enough mp3s to fill a
terabyte hard drive where each song is
10 times the number of drives to the
horizon that it would take to ride
around the world each time you set eyes
on one where each horizon is a head of
hairs and every hair there is the length
of a lifetime and each breath and that
life is the price of mount everest made
entirely by midas and that finally
describes it oh and it's increasing its
size so each time you listen to the song
again it'll be even more difficult to
comprehend
myself
[Music]
i was looking for words
that dave didn't use
[Music]